alors le personnage c'est un personnage
comme ça très costaud très musclé on
voit faire de la gym et tout en même
temps d'une grande fragilité
on a toujours l'impression qu'ils qui va
partir quoi ce deal et nicolas maîtresse
est assez joli c'est habile
scénaristiquement et au niveau du cinéma
c'est de dire on va montrer la force
plutôt de l'avoir la jouer comme ça on
va garder le jeu pour l'émotion la
maladresse le pathétique le ridicule le
grotesque le pato est ce que tout ce
personnage véhicule un peu comme le dr
sexe dans un autre registre un peu comme
dampierre d'irréversible voilà c'est des
registres que j'aime bien ouais alors on
souffre quand il fait de la muscu mais
on souffre encore plus quand on croise
son regard est quelque chose qui se
dégage de lui qui était assez pathétique
des risques quand on vous voit là vous
allez y allumer malicieux mais dans le
film vous êtes vraiment des cons paye
tout est possible il ya du jardin aussi
jean dujardin est excellent je ne sais
pas du tout j'ai pas la télé d'ailleurs
je n'ai pas la télé
non c'est pour ça que je n'ai jamais
jamais venu si j'avais l'ambition avant
non mais là jean dujardin je connaissais
pas et qui est très sympathique berlin
exceptionnel va me connaissait par
ailleurs claude perron que je
connaissais sans avoir la télévision et
demi que la mariée qui veut également
dans le bon dernier un créateur et une
flopée d'autres acteurs sont formidables
cas une grande réussite de boukhrief que
je salue le personnage est éminemment
doux et sympathique intègre authentique
voilà très bien on l'applaudît
ça sort le 14 avril
alors j'ai mis antisocial tout à l'heure
si vous n'êtes pas ramassé antisocial
gens vous en convenez nombreux vétérans
et d'écoles maternelles à quatre ans et
demi c'est quand même pas mal non
archives c'est assez c'est vrai le pire
c'est vrai et ensuite vous étiez à
l'école paul bert à conflans et on était
obligé de vous mettre du chatterton sur
la bouche pour vous clouer le bec fin et
hambourg enseigne mais bon en mai quand
laurent blanc est toujours celle cinq
ans et à fumier d'instituteurs
certainement pédophiles mais à l'époque
c'était motorisés qu'aujourd'hui qui m'a
foutu du chatterton sur la gauche franck
ans que j'avais volé sa maison bon il ya
cinq ans quand même je sais pas si j'ai
des regrets qui se finit je savais où il
habitait à acheter des glaces etc à
l'adresse portable j'ai tout et je me
rappelle qu'il avait une coccinelle
plusieurs fois j'aurais bien vu cette
coccinelle partir en fumée
voilà sans façon world is nothing signal
la seule chose qui arrive à vous calmer
un peu c'est la gym
ouaip ya pas que ça ait des parents
gentil surtout qu'ils m'ont un peu calmé
un peu dirigé la drogue la drogue assez
tôt et voilà une relation incestueuse
faisait beaucoup de sport
moi j'étais assez agitée à l'adolescence
ce qui vous calme est plutôt c'était le
cinéma ou passez votre vie enfermée dans
les salles je file et la réalité comme
vous je sais pas quand vous l'avez fait
du vous venez du fus la réalité
certainement aussi parce que mon fils
aime un vision vous continuez au cinéma
bref c'est encore pire
voilà il ya ainsi des mots bout de la
rue s'appelle palace voilà alors
j'allais vraiment papa qui était docteur
à la même rue je disais j'ai besoin
d'argent pour acheter des fournitures
scolaires ça se terminer par un billet à
10 15 ou 20 francs à vous rentriez à
deux heures de l'après midi une sortie à
minuit il faut peut-être enfin jeunes
gens rentraient plus tôt et puis un peu
plus vieux et antennes jeu retraite
et/ou de cette d'eric rohmer achats sont
d'ailleurs j'avais c'était la cie ne
s'agit pas de la cinéphilie
alors ensuite vous suivez l'orientation
paternelle pour devenir médecin fait
qu'à 35 de médecine jusqu'au jour où aux
urgences albert dupontel vous voyez
débarquer un mec de 20 balais
complètement bousillé par un accident de
moto et là vous vous dites il faut vivre
quoi il faut faire ce qu'on a envie de
faire dans la vie parce que finalement
ça ne tient à rien quoi en fait j'ai été
un peu
mis à pied pour un stage tout le monde
était soulager les malades comme les
médecins que je n'en aie un c'est vrai
j'avais été très frappé par six mois du
rejoint exactement à l'hôpital beaujon à
clichy franchement la nuit vous imaginez
pas ce qui se passe à frapper je me dis
si vivre savoir des émotions autant se
dépêcher des mois parce que c'est assez
aléatoire
là vous vous inscrivez à un cours de
théâtre et puis après on connaît la
suite il ya eu d'abord le one man show
qui était extraordinaire c'est à dire il
est des sketches comme le bac français
comme rambo et c'est un truc que j'ai
pas compris vous a vu un tel succès
quand vous avez commencé à faire des
sketchs bien je vous ai dit non ce que
j'espère c'est du cinéma carrière je
vais toujours faire du cinéma mais le
spectacle a été la poterne qui m'a
permis de rentrer dans la forteresse du
showbiz c'est une sorte de cri primal
mais je trouvais ça pauvre et frustrant
que je voulais faire du ciné bernie la
bande dessinée du spectacle le créateur
et la branche cinéma attaque nos
prochains la fin mai de horst a toujours
un corps à corps à ce spectacle voilà il
ya eu dernier évidemment le créateur
ensuite l'acteur avec des films aussi
important que la maladie de sachs de
ville alors vous êtes très lonesome
cowboy un vous vous êtes très anti
société du spectacle dj le compte à
rendre à personne je vis comme gandhi
je n'ai besoin de rien on ne peut pas
m'avoir le vrai luxe dans ce métier
c'est la liberté du diamant ou de dire
oui je suis aussi franc que bush
ouais non c'est vrai vous un peu discret
et voilà suffit d'être marginalisés
pourquoi pas mais je suis un peu discret
c'est tout je suis pas je suis pas
hystérique avec les médias j'avais
failli être un peu les gens à la télé
c'est la culture de l'ennui la télé
comme ça vous êtes une agressivité jeu
précis mais c'est vrai que moi j'ai pas
la télé depuis dix ans je m'en passe
très bien et heureusement je vais pas je
vois beaucoup de films j'ai 800 dvd
milka set gilles les bois etc
et voilà et la télé qu'on arrache à
l'automne j'ai rien à faire j'ai regardé
c'est fou le chose de choses inutiles à
part votre émission mains de choses
inutiles qu'on peut voir non mais je
reviens mais je pense que cette émission
est utile
je vais souvent ya un procès par exemple
on avait fait un gros procès et sur
bernie sur la violence au cinéma et sur
les versions parle pas ce film là
d'ailleurs pas taillé aux moins de 12
ans vient de baptiser donc il est pas si
loin que ça toutefois je mets donc j'ai
pas la télé mais le cinéma c'est un faux
procès ce que le cinéma est un lieu
protégé salus de polémiques d'expression
de débat mais ses protégés ont remporté
un seul de cinéma au hasard le même
quotidien variait facilement famille
c'est franchement et ses goûts et c'est
un consommateur crétins tant pis pour
lui par conte la télévision rendre ma
chambre d'hôtel crash convoi puis sur le
bouton je tombe et ce sur lci et semaine
dernière les mecs qui brûle dans la jeep
les américains dépecer par la foule
j'étais très choquée parce que j'étais
paperasse ah ouais donc une perversité
eux ils se cachent derrière l'alibi de
l'information entre l'île une
information et voyeurisme il ya un truc
une frontière qui franchit allègrement
donc le procès de la violence au cinéma
montcuq quoi ça n'existe pas assez c'est
le mec qui va au cinéma voir un film
c'est ce qui va voir sauf si c'est un
combat sort c'est très intéressant et
tester la tb comme ça je n'aime pas ce
que me fais pas mon temps voilà sauf
quand je suis à bien sûr c'est pas une
attitude un peu snob non écoutez
franchement d'abord elle est
involontaire c'est un jour un jour m'a
coupé cas parce que je payais pas donc
au départ puis la voix a appuyé me suis
rendu compte que je pensais que je m'en
passe est très bien bon sinon même un
peu snob ne pas payer le câble